الى تطورات في تونس حيث مددت السلطات حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد الى نهايه العام الجاري
وفق ما جاء في مرسوم صدر في الجريده
الرسميه هذه هي المره الاولى التي تمدد
فيها حاله الطوارئ لعام كامل حيث كانت
تمديدها يتراوح بين شهر وثلاثه اشهر منذ
استئناف العمل بها عام 2015 عاقبه تفجير
في العاصمه تونس
ايضا الينا من تونس مراد اليعقوبي
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي وكذلك من تونس
والمحلل السياسي سيد الحسن لماذا تم تمديد
حاله الطوارئ
لاول مره لسنه كامله ما هو المبرر
الحقيقه تونس تعيش في حاله طوارئ منذ سنه
2012 ودائما مكان هناك تمديد في حاله
الطوارئ
نتيجه هذه السنوات في ظل حاله الطوارئ نعم
سابقا كان هناك تمديد بشهر 3 اشهر وسته
اشهر وهذه المره يبدو اننا تمديد حاله
طوارئ 11 شهرا دفعه واحده الان طبعا من
المعلوم انه في ظل حاله الطوارئ ثم مجموعه
من الصلاحيات
ومجموعه من القوانين التي تبقى سريعه
المفعول والتي تسهل عمل همم يعني بعض
مؤسسات الدوله
السياسي كما على المستوى الاجتماعي
وايضا حتى على المستوى الاقليمي تونس يعني
مهدده من ما يحدث على المستوى الاقليمي
خاصه اذا تحدثنا على ليبيا وما يحدث في
ليبيا من الواضح ايضا انه على المستوى
الامني اليسا هناك همم ليس هناك يعني هناك
تهديدات على المستوى الامني ومن اجل ذلك
وقعت تلبيس في حاله الطوارئ ولكن تمديد
هذه المده يبدو انه جاء اطول من المعتاد
وهنا السؤال الذي اطرحه لسيد مراد اليعقوب
برايك لماذا مدد الرئيس قيس صعيد حاله
الطوارئ هذه المره على غير العاده لمده
اطول
بتبيعه الحال همم التفسير الوحيد لهذا
الوضع او لهذا لهذا القرار ان هناك تخبط
من قبل همم سوره سياسيه يعني المقصود هو
قيس سعيد وهناك رفع لحاله التاهب دون وجود
اسباب مقنعه لان الوضع همم لم يختلف عام
عن صديقه هناك مشاكل سياسيه وهذه لا يمكن
ان نتجنبها او نواجهها
بتمديد طوارئ عسكري هو في الواقع يتم في
حاله الحرب او في حالات الازمات الكبرى في
حين ان تونس لم تعرف منذ يعني فتره طويله
الا بعض مسيرات او اشياء من هذا القبيل
وهذه لا تعتبر همم ولكن المخيف الامر ربما
بسبب الوضع الاقتناء والعذر الذي يعيش
التي يعيشها قيس ربما سيمر الى اجراءات
اكثر همم خطوره تجاه المعاريفيه وهو همم
ربما يحاول ان يعني يستميل القوات
العسكريه وضعها تحت يده من اجل ان يمارس
بكل حريه وهذا طبعا همم يعني ينحرف عن
الصراع السياسي اللي يدخله في وضع اخر لا
يمكن ان يبشر بخير لكل البلاد هل سيد بن
حسن هذا هو المتوقع همم محاوله كما يقول
همم ضيفنا مراد اللي يعقوب بالاستماله
الاجهزه الامنيه والقوات المسلحه همم لكي
تكون مع قيس سعيد الذي يعاني من حاله عزله
واختناق كما تقول المعارضه وكما وصف ذلك
يعقوب
هناك اعلان لحاله الطوارئ
2012 الان القوات الامنيه والكرات
العسكريه من الواضح ان مثقله بالاعداء
يعني هناك الكثير من الاعداء على كاهل هذه
القوات والرئيس قيس سعيد في حاجه دائما
الى شحده من هذه القوات خاصه الى تحدثنا
عن الجيش
الحرس الوطني
لهذه القوات الامنيه من محاربه التهريب من
حمايه الهدهد من الحفاظ على الامن العام
من الحفاظ على مؤسسه الدوله
ان هناك بعض المظاهرات او بعض الانشطه
التي بين طفلين تسمى نقابيه وتموس من
المؤسسات الدوله
همم بعض الاشخاص العاملين لدى الدوله
الامر لا يتعلق بمواجهه خصوم الرئيس
السيسي عيد لانه من الواضح ان المعارضه
الى حد هذه اللحظه لا تسال تقبع في مربع
يمكن تسميته بمربع السادس والعشرين من
سوريا ولم تتقدم ايه خطوه حتى يمكنها ان
تهدد الرئيس قيس سعيد ضع احد اهم نقاط قوه
رئيس في الحاله السياسيه هي المعارضه التي
تكشف
فكل طرف منهما يقفوا على على على جانبين
متقابلين ولا يخفان على ارضيه واحده تمكن
من اجراء الحوار كان بينهما المعارضه لا
تزال تستمع الى صوتها الداخليه والرئيس
سعيد لا يزال ينفذ خطته كما اعلن عليها في
التزام من ثاني
المحطاتها سيد مراد ما الذي يقلق المعارضه
من تمديد حاله طوارئ اذا كانت هي مفروضه
من الاساس اا سنوات
اا نحن بحثنا خاصه في اطالتها لمده سنه
ااه طبعا ضيفكم الكريم قالوا قال انه ليس
هناك اي اشكال فسير فعلا هو هذا السؤال
لماذا تمديدها بسنه الارجح ان قيس سعيد
سيدخل في مواجهه اطول نظرا للمشكل في
الانتخابات لضعف الاقدام وغيره وبالتالي
ربما كان يتصور ان الحل السياسي الذي
سيقدمه انهاء خريته للطريق سيكون سريعا
ولكن تبين له ان هذه الخطه لن تتم بسرعه
كما كان يتوقعها فضلا عن انه اصبح يستعد
لمواجهه التحركات ربما تقودها المنظمات
وهذه طبعا
مواجهتها اظن ان رسالته التي وجهها
البارحه هي رساله الى المنظمات النقابيه
همم ارهابها همم تخويفها حتى لا تتواصل
يعني تحركاتها لانه ينتظر ذلك وهذا ادخل
في اا موقفه وفي سياسته وفي رؤيته هو يرى
ان هذه الاجسام الوسيطه لا مكان لها وهذه
الاجسام الان ليست مثل الاحزاب السياسيه
التي هي احزاب مدنيه ليست لها قوه فعليه
لفرز لشروطها في الشارع بينما التحركات
النقابيه تكون فعلا نظرا لتحريا لان
العمال هم اكبر قطاع ويبدو ان استعداد
سعيد لمواجهه العمال الواسع هو الذي دفعه
الى تمديد هذه الفتره وهو لا ينتظر ان يحل
مشاكله قريبا لذلك اخذ فتره اطول همم
يحاول ان يفرز رايته شكرا جزيلا لكم من
تونس الاكاديمي والمحل السياسي ونشكر كذلك
من تونس بالحسن اليحاوي الكاتب والمحل
الاساسي شكرا لكم